اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها مجموعه من
الملفات وفي عناوينها
عام على الحرب في اوكرانيا ماذا حققت
روسيا وما هي فرص احلال السلام
دعم غربي انطلاقا من اسلحه دفاعيه ووصولا
لاسلحه ثقيله وهجوميه هل الدعم الغربي كاف
وهل ساهم في قلبي موازين القوه
وهل نجحت الضغوط الاقتصاديه على موسكو ومن
الخاسر الاكبر من العقوبات روسيا ام الغرب
ونحييكم مشاهدينا ومتابعينا الى التفاصيل
قبل عام من الان وتحديدا في فجر الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير بدات الحرب في
اوكرانيا باعلان رئيس روسيا فلاديمير
بوتين بدا عمليه عسكريه خاصه قال انها
تهدف لي نزع السلاح من اوكرانيا
واليوم وبعد عام تغيرت المعطيات فالاشهر
المنصرمه شهدت انتصارات وانتكاسات للقوات
الروسيه في الشمال والشرق وكذلك في الجنوب
الاوكراني وحتى قرب مركز القرار الاوكراني
اي كيس خريطه الميدان تشير الى احتدام
المعارك في بخمو تلك المدينه الصغيره
الواقعه شمال مقاطعه
مع ثلاثه مقاطعات اخرى بعد استفتاء جرى في
سبتمبر الماضي بخموت او ارتيموفسكي كما
يسميها الاعلام الروسي في اشاره الى
تسميتها القديمه تشكل اهميه استراتيجيه
للطرفين مراقبين اهميتها لروسيا كونها
تسعى لتحقيق انتصارات تقدمها في الداخل
حيث تقع باخموت على طريقه رئيسيه يؤدي الى
مدينتي
وكرامه كما ان السيطره عليها تعني بناء خط
دفاع على مقاطعه لغاز التي اعلنت موسكو
سيطره عليها بالكامل في المقابل تكتسب
مخموت اهميه رمزيه للاوكرانيين بسبب ضراوه
المعارك حولها ومده صمودها كما انها تعتبر
خط دفاع على مدينتي
القريبتين وذلك في وقت تشهد بقيه الجبهات
قتالا محدودا وقصفا متبادلا بين الطرفين
وسط توقعات غربيه بتحضير روسيا لهجوم جديد
بدايه الربيع
تاريخ الرابع والعشرين من فبراير حسم
التخمينات باعلان بوتين الحرب على
اوكرانيا
بدايه الاجتياح سيطر الجيش الروسي على
مناطق واسعه في خرسون في السادس والعشرين
من فبراير عام 2022 وسعت موسكو الهجمات في
كافه الاتجاهات الاوكرانيه في الثامن
والعشرين من فبراير من عام 2022 دخلت
روسيا واوكرانيا في مفاوضات لكنها تعثرت
الرابع والعشرون من مارس النيتو يقرر
تسليح اوكرانيا الحادي والعشرون من ابريل
بوتين يعلن السيطره النسبيه على مدينه
ماريوبولو الاستراتيجيه السابع والعشرون
من ابريل كيف تعترف بتقدم القوات الروسيه
شرقا وسيطرتها على مدن في اقليم دامبس في
يوليو من عام 2022 روسيا تعلن السيطره
الكامله على مقاطعه لوغانس
سبتمبر 2022 روسيا تضم اربع مناطق
اوكرانيه في استفتاء شعبي
السابع من ديسمبر بوتين يقول خطر الحرب
النوويه يتصاعد في فبراير من عام 2023
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في كييف
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من موسكوس
المحلل العسكري ومن كياف الدكتور الكسندر
بجمالوف مدير المعهد الوطني الاوكراني
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه اهلا بكم
معك سيد سيرجي سيد سرجي عام الان على
بدايه العمليه العسكريه الروسيه ولم يتوقع
احد ان تطول ولكن في هذه المرحله وفي
معادله الربح والخساره لمن تميل الكفه ان
كان هناك مستفيد او رابح في هذه المرحله
بالتحديد
السلام عليكم
السؤال الاهم الذي
معلق في في الهواء هل كان من الممكن
تجنب نشوب هذه الحرب هل كان من الممكن
اصلا
الامتناع عنها نعم
ويعود السبب
لتشوب هذه الحرب ليس لروسك ولو يسموها في
الغرب دوله عدوانيه
والاحتلال والعدوان والى اخره ولكن كان
هناك تحذيرات جديه من كرملين قائلا ان
يرجى عدم انتشار حلف الناتو شرقا يرجى عدم
توفير القواعد العسكريه الهجوميه الغربيه
قريبا من الحدود
الروسيه
لابد من تحليل هذه الازمه سلميا بما فيها
عن طريق
اتفاقات
مع
حدث بعد ذلك بعد ذلك اعترفت فرنسا
والمانيا وهي دول
ضامنه لاتفاقات ميمسك ان الغايه الوحيده
من تلك الاتفاقات كسب الوقت وتعزيز
وتجاهل
رغبه روسيا في احترام حقوقها المشروع في
حمايه
السياده والاستقلال اذا
قرار الذي تم اتخذه من قبل رئيس بوتين في
ثالث وعشرين العمل الماضي كان مجبرا وكان
ويضطر الرئيس بوتين على اتخاذ مثل هذا
القرار انه حتى في ديسمبر عام
اقترحت موسكو للغرب
لنجلس ونناقش التداعيات المحتمله
لتصاعد النساء الوارد بين روسيا والغرب
وكان الرد الغربي بعد ذلك ما عليكم
الحق في انضمام
ونحن نواصل هذا المسير يعني حضرتك تعتبر
بان هذه الحرب كانت
يعني كان بالامكان ان لا تكون من الاساس
دكتور الكسندر هل تعتقد كضيفي بان هذه
الحرب دخلتها موسكو مضطره كما قال دخلها
بوتين مضطرا كما قال لحمايه حدوده من
انتشار الناتو وبان الغرب واوكرانيا
تتحملان مسؤوليه اندلاع واستمرار هذه
الحرب
ابدا مجرد كلام دعايه وليس لو كانت روسيا
خافت من النيتو لان صاحبت كل القوات من
الحدود نيتو حاليا هناك تقريبا يعني وجود
العسكري بسيط جدا يعني عدد قليل جدا على
حدود بين الحرف الشمال الاطلسي والروسيا
مباشره يعني كل القوات اللي كانت موجوده
هناك على الحدود نيتو مباشره منسحبه
وموجوده حاليا في ساحه القتال في اوكرانيا
السبب الوحيد يعني السبب الوحيد في هذه
الحرب العدوان الروسي والسبب العدوان
الروسي الذي لهيه سياسيه الروسيه التي لم
تتغير من ايام السوفيتي فكانت وما زالت
دوله مستعمره دوله امبراليه قوه امبراليه
فهذا جزء من هذه القويه قويه الى اعتبار
ان كل الاراضي اللي كانت ارادت على
الاتحاد السوفيتي وكذلك حتى الدول الدول
التي كانت في اطار الاتحاد في هذه تحت
النفوذ التي يسمى دور الشرق الاوروبيه
وسط الاوروبيه التي كانت تابعه للنظام
السوفيتي كذلك موسكو تعتبر انه يعني من
حقها بس نفوذها على هذه الدول يعني في ذلك
يعني في هذا الجانب السياسي وليس في
العسكريه لب القضيه
فهذه هي المخاوف الروسيه التي كانت وما
زالت لحد الان موجوده في اللي هي سببت
سببت في هذا الحرب تعتقد
مرور كل هذا الوقت البعض يقول بان روسيا
لن تحقق اهدافها بعد سنه البعض يقول بانها
لم تحمي حدودها ولم
تقوم بابعاد كل المخاطر التي كانت تتحدث
عنها منذ البدايه هل تورط بوتين ومن هنا
ياتي تجنب حضرتك الحديث في بدايه سؤال عن
مستفيد او عن غالب في هذه الخطه
في
ما يخوز تم التحقيقها خلال الساده هذه
نتيجه الاستفتاء
انضمت الى روسيا محافظه
لوغاسك بالكامل ومقاطعه دونيسك بمقدار 95%
ومقاصره خرسون
درجه عاليه جدا
ومحافظه زبروجيا ايضا طبعا موضوع شبه
جزيره القرن يمكن ننساها بالكامل
وبحر ازرف تحولت الى بحر روسيه داخليه لا
يمكن دخولها الا بالسماح من قياده البحريه
ولكن سيد معنى جزيره القرم على الاوكران
نسيانها
دكتور الكسندر هل يمكنك ان تنسى جزيره
القرم تماما
ابدا ابدا فهناك ليس فقط الوقيان هناك عمل
السكان المحقلين المصريين اللي هم
المسلمين يعني بالمناسبه تقدر يعني الذين
هم وقفوا الى جانب او
كرانيا والقياداتهم السياسيه كذلك يعني
موجوده حاليا يعني في الخارج لانه بعضهم
يعني اعتقل يعني في جزء كبير منهم
يعني هذا صحيح هذا صحيح ولكن هناك واقع
الواقع اليوم يقول بان جزيره القرن تحت
سيطره
2014 ويقول اكثر من ذلك اسمح لي فقط لاكمل
السؤال ويقول اكثر من ذلك بان روسيا من
خلال العمليه العسكريه هذه تمكنت ونجحت في
قضم اراض اوكرانيه جديده
الروسيه نجحت في فرح باب يعني باب قرم من
جديد في اعاده فتح هذا الباب لان الموضوع
كرم كان تقريبا شبه متروك متروك وحتى
القياده الاوكرانيه قبل تجديد العدوان
الروسي هذا الجديد يعني قبل سنه يعني كان
بصراحه كل خطط عنه بالنسبه
استعاده بطرق سلميه طرق دبلوماسيه اما
حاليا فان قدره عنا القدره عسكريه
لاستعاده قرم يعني الجيش الروسي الفشل
يعني الفشل في كل المخططاته يعني خلال
يعني هذا العام يعني
بالانتكاسات وليس بايه فهذا يعني
بانتصارات يعني حتى حاليا ليست لديهم قدره
في استمرار الهجوم يعني هل هذا صحيح سيد
سير هل فعليا موسكو بدات تنهكها هذه
العمليه العسكريه والبعض يقول كذلك بانها
فشلت حتى التحالف مع اطراف اخرى يعني
اليوم نحن نتحدث عن تحالف غربي
امريكي يعني اوروبي امريكي مع كييف ولكن
هل فتحت هذه الحرب المجالي روسيا لتتحالف
كذلك مع اطراف اخرى ومن هي
الكلام ضيفكم في كيف يدل على ان قرار
الرئيس بوتين قبل سنه كان قرار صحيح ولابد
منه لان
الاهداف التي اشار اليها رئيس بوتين قبل
ساده لا تزال
قائمه وسوف يتم تحقيقها بالكامل بناء الشك
الاهداف هي
ازاله النازيه الحكم من النازي الحالي في
اوكرانيا وعدم انضمام اوكرانيا الى حرفه
النيتو لا مجال اطلاقا
وايضا
نزع سلاح ولا اخره طبعا الى اهداف هذه
ولكن
اكياس اوكرانيا مدعومه صارت اكثر من قبل
فيما يخص
دخولها لناتو هذا اولا صار هناك دعم
اوروبي اقوى حتى من قبل وفيما يخص الشفاف
النزيه من الداخل الاوكراني لم يتم ذلك
وبالتالي هل استعصت كياف على بوتين
الغربي
لاوكرانيا يزداد ويزداد بشكل ملحوظ بما
فيه ادعم السياسي والدبلوماسي والاقتصادي
والعسكري
والاعلامي بلا شك
فاذا بدات المساعدات وتعزيزات الغربيه قبل
سنه من نقلات المشاه المنقرضه نوع ام 1013
من احد حرب يدعم يدور الكلام حول نقل
الدبابات حديثه
والى اخره ومنظمات الدفاع الجوي المتطوره
ويدرك حتى
حول امكانيه
روسيا يقف معها اول شيء جمهوريه ايران
الاسلاميه
يعني هذا هذا دليل دليل رائع هذا دليل
رائع على ضروره
يقول انه الغايه في دعم اوكرانيا هو
توطيط الديمقراطيه ما هي الديمقراطيه في
اوكرانيا الان حيث لا معارضه ولا مقاومه
واي واحد يعبر عن راي يختلف عن الرسمي
يحبسوه ويسجنون واي واحد يطلع يشتري
وكل واحد يعبر عن رايه بكل
وممنوع خروج البلاد من قبل الرجال ب 16
الى 60 سنه منعا اي واحد ياخذوه على الجيش
ويجبروه على الذهاب الى ميدان المعركه
لخوض القطاع
والتربيه حتى من الروضه من روضه الاطفال
هناك اهادي تكون ان روسي طيب هو روسي ميت
فهذا هو
دكتور الكسندر سيقول لك بعضهم روسيا
وكانها ترى نفسها وصيه على كيف هذا ليس
موضوعنا خلينا نبقى في كل ما هو تطورات
على الارض وحتى تطورات سياسيه يعني اليوم
مثلا نحن تبعنا تصريحات جد مهمه للجانب
الصيني الصين تدخل على الخط وتقترح
امكانيه حلحله هذه الازمه وهنا سؤال سيد
سيرجي هل يمكن ان ياتي الحل من الصين التي
اكد على اعتمادها على الامور او على
الحلول الدبلوماسيه واكدت كذلك من جهه
اخرى بان تسليح كياف المتواصل سيفاقم هذه
الازمه
الغاء الحقيقيه الغربيه في هذه العمليه
الخاصه استنزاف روسيا
اوكرانيا هي مجرد وسيله يعني اللحم البشري
اللحمه البشري تزوده الولايات المتحده
بالسلاح والاتحاد الاوروبي وغيري الاداره
السياسيه الصينيه تدرك تماما ان الولايات
المتحده تصر على حفاظ هيمناتها
والغايه ولا روسيا هي الصين
لذلك المبادرات الصينيه وطبعا الموقف
الصيني يميل الى دعم روسيا وهذا مبين
وبالامس كان هناك مفاوضات على مستوى رفيع
في موسكو والشهر المقبل سوف يكون اللقاء
الشخصي بين الرئيس السيدي
الذي سوف يزور موسكو ويلتقي بالرئيس
الروسي يعني هناك تطورات واضحه
الصين
تساند روسيا ما رايك سيد سرجاوي هل يمكن
ان ياتي الحل الحقيقي من الصين
بالنسبه للخليه يعني فهو
الصين باختصار مهم جدا يعني مهم جدا يعني
وارد من قبل الصين
لروسيا خط احمر اللي هو النبوي وهذا
الجانب مهم جدا يعني
دكتور الكسندر مدير المعهد الوطني
الاوكراني لدراسات الاستراتيجيه شكرا لك
ومن موسكو المحلله العسكري شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
سنبقى دائما في نفس هذا الاطار ولكن مع
تفاصيل صله بعد الفاصل نناقش
هل غيرت دعم الغربي لكاف قواعد الحرب
باوكرانيا وهل هو كافر لصدي هجوم روسي او
هجوم روسي جديد
[موسيقى]